hello hey don't you join the show I'm
having a blast is he talking to audience
audience member to audience yeah he does
this it's like a thing to connect does
he know they don't talk back yeah does
he know it hasn't it's the voices on the
Daniels voices those keys you just from
the Bradshaw McGinnis hey I've arrived
yeah Sean you look dif the last time I
saw you don't touch it bring it bring
it's going you've had a busy shot so I
did show me your sweet bounded I got a
band aid of a skateboarding dinosaur I
don't know if he's right here oh ok
dinosaur and wearing a helmet things I
do for internet television but that's
definitely a skateboarding dinosaur you
guys I mean you're gonna have the flu
tomorrow like yeah all in sick for the
next three weeks yeah sorry guys that
Thun shot was a real boy sounds a bad
idea yeah you look different to the last
time I saw you Thanks yeah oh right cuz
of the the scanning face yeah last time
I saw you was in NBA 2k is if T is it
that I don't look like an abomination of
nature ok yeah it doesn't look like
you've been beaten about the face with
household appliances horrific bruising
so we understand it's like you your skin
paint was like buff revealing the robot
oh yeah that's fun that's fun I've we're
not here to play NBA 2k15 and it would
have been on the show maybe but uh it
got bumped anything could have happened
no no anything that will happen can't
happen good yeah I'm sony or yeah Sony
of America decided to sound recall sony
entender entertainment America's jani so
nice they decided to finally put that
ski it slightly to finally put a ribbon
and I feel like the only reason that
this has been released in north america
is because of like soft core internet
trolling like everyone just saying you
guys never baby then it comes out three
yeah comes out and everybody's like
turns out we don't know what the [ __ ]
member actually
yes would you call it the actual title
of the game it risom fit rhythm babe
ribbon viv ribbit ribbit simply is the
name of the brownish called so this is a
game that was released in japan and then
released in europe a couple of months
later and like 99 never released in
north america it's the folks who made
proper the wrapper yeah none uh-huh
right boys here Messiah matsuura menos
yeah yeah yeahs all major minors
majestic march quite a wheel and played
man leading on the way you read whistle
you got 14 games oh yeah so it's ad
today on a ps3 and Vita MPs 4000 really
but Pete said I think with this game is
that you can use audio CDs to generate
levels yeah only works on the ps3
version okay let's jump right in you're
gonna do it yeah well I think first I
have you played a poor yeah only like a
little bit this morning and then like 10
years ago oh yeah i am going about 10
years it is so it's pretty simple
there's only four buttons but then they
combine the buttons to me not let's just
get to it I'll [ __ ] also I was reading
the description of it and it sounded a
lot like a bit trip runner yes Mary Mary
you're saying that earlier which is you
know I mean this is not gonna go well
it's way harder what you wanted to Troy
I love you uh no but I mean I know what
to do what song is it its drone Parappa
the rapper oh [ __ ] this is a song for oh
we're instantly going into your CD yeah
okay uh what is hair are four buttons
and you're like what are they one of
them is fall down and die you don't know
what it's doing such a bad job another
one is jump there's a duck it'll fall
down and die so hard so the problem is
is that like that's trying go that's X
okay right but the problem is that there
are modifiers on all these so sometimes
the circle has like a triangle on it
sometimes you have to do or two and
square it starts off really easy and
then it just Oh see this is really
embarrassing this is what maybe maybe
you should switch to your backup song so
I got turn into a work bring it back can
you guys let that CD playing we've got
the CD yeah don't use that use the
default music what just do we leave here
at least so people can see what I do the
tutorial or is the story
I don't know do you have to is there a
tutorial I think you got ticket that
senior back judit oh yeah Jim we will
have a seat turn forget that CD I'll get
that CD like Danny says okay it's been a
while since I used optical media okay
hey could you or any blog plug out that
CD thanks just put it right out
evergreen I don't say no there's no
tutorial man play would fit Riven disk I
did that already here we go is it none
all right do an easy what does what do
an easy one and then after that do your
special song Peter you know which one
I'm talking about yeah I do okay plug
out that disc so plug on this CD plug at
the disc so this is the reason to get it
on PS how much is it I don't know sex
box it cost you like six bucks Mary what
are the four buttons you guys don't are
buttons which does the loop are like r1
or r2 if you fancy okay what just
happened someone plugged a disc out yeah
did you a plug into the disc in or plug
it out oh did you think you'd be able to
make one small error in speech and not
like it ride that one for the rest of
the segment this is so much easier than
what are you doing that last one do you
hit it at the beginning of the lead in
it like right when the foot touches the
the elements are so that's our button
what's this one that's an X what is that
a tumble sure vid ribbon vam rhythm or
Valen ribbon bed ribbing a vibrating
repairs ribbon ribbon look the bunny's
called Vitry they breathe of it ribbon
to get those waves there were two
sequels to this as well well but they
were like considerably different than
Rick given right one of them created
levels using predefined like pictures
like pixelated pictures and there was
another one forget how that one works
xr1 so you got this are 10 I can just do
backflips the whole time why weren't you
doing this whoo x mother ones oh yeah
okay nutted yourself on that column
chris is there any way of getting down
hit down is the wrong way of making it
so you're not shaking anymore no you
always have that if you mess up yes how
many times can you mess up I don't know
you're the expert on this video game Oh
relative expert in two things nope I
didn't do it from the era before seizure
warnings to freaking you add a little
bit that's your flu shot okay this is
like nominee alone arsenal vectors since
the veterans yeah all these graphics are
done using actors premature it's fun as
if anyone care I'll turn it to about I
care about you Chris who's gonna keep
talking over each other yes vector
graphics hey you don't you don't see a
lot of that yeah why are you a frog net
cuz i was doing poorly UD evolve from
rabbit to frog that's not a natural
order of things if you do really crap
like Peter I become a worm I remember
people in the chowder like this came out
in two thousand what the hell I remember
when this came out in Europe thinking
this looks like a position that was 15
years ago Sean you want to give this one
a shot no yes look at this multiplayer
get your multiplier the whole way around
first what button is l where l 2 down or
something yeah there you go Oh feel it
do it Frogger yeah I know what's up x.x
you got that ribbon ribbon with him huh
oh what's that one L down or you were
there just the worst ar-ar-ar-ar yes or
or or or or oh it's worm yeah you didn't
all right let you go let's do these do
you know what you want to do your son
yeah I'll do it all right do i switch up
plug in the disc [ __ ] plug in the
comment you plug up you plug it up or
you plug it out yeah okay look over
there you get the book it up x plug it
in plug it in listen you got you got
bumped back up to rabbit you better get
your rabbit game on
just put it in oh my good plug it in
terrible I wished Japan were in the ER
visit sometime yes yeah right hit start
get out here oh quit AMI uh back down oh
so I for one I'm delighted that this
game is out but I will not be purchasing
why are you delighted that this game is
out because it like job because it's a
definitely if you have like historical
no dress like a in fact I'd like change
kind of a computer games from the
violent like you know come back are we
released our sort of kept in the in mix
in circulation I like it because it's
because this was a game to people in
Europe were like you know Mergen get
this oh okay so it's kind of like the
fact that it's been finally released
here says it was like an exclusive oh
[ __ ] you felt like you were part of a
cool Club no we nobody for down no are
down are RL aa down so the modifiers are
on these ones oh [ __ ] so instead of
regular so you just you do it they're
like this is terrible you got this whoa
what the song is this this is sean's
choice by the way Peter asked me to pick
a song and I picked snake eater from the
video game Metal Gear Solid 3 snake
eater this is a casa it's great so it's
gonna be about seven minutes long yeah
yeah there's gonna be a worm before oh
yeah Chris the tired of this [ __ ]
you're a worm right now I [ __ ] you
mean the truth the truth just a
man Peter I believe in you so you
believe are one or down it doesn't even
work seem to be in with music no it's
not at all maybe not the best song suck
it or no this is the best song
objectively oh my job' not for vid we're
going in the other direction that
difficult Sean you gotta play your own
song yeah I'm gonna fail it even cook it
yeah we're gonna play one more alright
God you want to you have a glass one I
want to I to how many more times we have
to play loads and so many as we want
awesome all right you keep pick your
trap ok i will say let's save for for
the last we're [ __ ] playing wow twice
more space with the current CD that's
right run this one have any traction on
this for what was the former smell your
solid ah that was teary I've gone
through yet three is the one we just did
what's what was one that was Parappa the
rapper I got a really hard one before
before do it you did I believe let's see
those euro gaming skills oh yeah because
it's I see those let's see what a gyro
game assume you're just gaming cool
getting my skills but then they're
playing pretend you're playing sensible
soccer on your BBC micro back home and
Waterford god damn it stupid rabbit I
hated you then I don't you now isn't out
the waterford way no this is not 0 1 no
that's all no this one is complicated as
hell yeah good times I could do this one
now after that like the bronze level
look it's like they're not even
stationary young use your dad even serve
disappointed if you think of young Danny
just trying to make it big in the big
city one day young Danny is wondering
why they would release this game 15
years Danny's like I can this is neat
but I can't wait until they have
spiritual successors to this game that
are way better yeah like bit.trip runner
to you oculus rift support aki let's
have ever been what if this game was a
first-person platformer with rift
support when that'd be great
in my local gamestop this was like yep
there was always like 20 of these in the
pre-owned sexy really ya know cuz I
think they sold it for like 20 whatever
euro or pounds back then Juan froggy
have all this is gonna do is make people
start asking for a cheery reduce
improper now that would have been a
better decision to be honest with you I
bet this one took one person in it away
ATA tu rerelease like this Parappa HD
really look better than just Parappa
they just want to play it again sure
because our silly median makes it so
that you can like and like that stuff
yeah that's old but I'd considerable
amount of effort can you just play the
PSone classics or the ps1 whatever
working it's a PlayStation 1 disc even
get from the ps3 yeah so uh your
question again are you talking for the
music or just generally you play Parappa
the rapper PlayStation 1 on your ps3
with the disc but a skate backwards
compatible one right no that's only ps2
you're kidding well the ps1 is that
everyone says it's to me anytime gonna
[ __ ] up I did not know that boys do are
you guys qualified for your job hahahaha
you're our resident playing old video
games dude yeah that's true that is true
man no no I do not yeah so yes tell what
you I'm gonna start ebaying ps1 games
incredibly difficult I don't marry no
heckle me from over there oh my is that
this is right in there yeah y'all you
gotta be on set but I'm not even the
obstacles are definitely not in sync
with the rhythm I'll tell you that much
kids this game is very difficult 24 yeah
I'll try it again I'm beat 24 come on
just let it happen what are you so busy
we have the piece de resistance up after
this yeah all right I'm not gonna play
that one cuz which one is that oh that's
your specialty it's the song that there
is a running back in game spot for the
past I feel like nine months maybe I
think it's Mary's idea whereas if you
can get this edited into any like video
on the site there's a kitty jar how much
is in the yard understand
I am married to get out of the room
right now art is Peter technically
winning this best yes that's gonna have
to that's gonna have to be adjudicated I
feel like by a jury of his peers I got
space monkey into a video on the site
okay technically I gave you the file oh
my god maybe only gave me the file but I
asked his one really difficult I could
have no worried by by other means Mary
give me that money you got the jar what
do you mean I didn't earn it why sure
what I'm the water smile is being on air
am I not okay so okay all right so does
this cash does he win this face monkey
it's going towards beer if I win it
anyway so that's true okay before we
play before we play I see let's count it
up space money pot jar wait does not
meet the bike with to spend it on pot
monkey god we could do that that's fine
oh it's already that's been apart 510
this is way more here and I thought to
be listen fake money that's a fake
payday 2 money bonus bucks thanks baby
it's probably tie 1520 there's five euro
and here's oh there's a two-year-old on
it and then we're two Australians no
Singapore box Jesus right for the
international joint wanted to make it
appealing to folks from all nations ok
you guys vide solution okay yeah but
this just twenty bucks there if you beat
this level oh I have to beat the level
hahaha all right Peter you can do this
crank it up oh my goodness here Rob
every time you hear the song this is
doable you can see why there was a best
to try and get this song into a video
and also have to be like at least 30
seconds 40 Howard Howe has just not been
done yet you just sneak it into any old
yeah you just put in the fries entire
video review the alien isolation video
review the Destiny raid guide videos
just put this into an NBA 2k15 gameplay
you're killing it buddy you got this
uh I think the closest we came was
trying to put it into the donkey kong
country tropic jeffries one but it
didn't quite land 40 seconds of this
song it turns out is actually quite a
lot she's actually on a lot [ __ ] is this
part of our music library is that come
on froggy get them space monkey books no
this is what we were listening to while
we were playing vipra than in Europe
that whole time stock the shelves stock
the shows you're not digging it Shawn
know you live in it I'm just trying to
folk here already [ __ ] you can do this
Peter come on get it together man oh
it's Rob Rob said this cows 30 seconds
flat novio 30 seconds flat with novia
novia was never in the fashion one we've
got ok I'll do together you guys shut up
we've got you go rob henry much
contesting let's definitely not talk
after 29 seconds ok oh yeah ok nice
nullifying the bend Peter yeah five
bucks for me to shut up this whole yeah
oh wait so it doesn't count cuz you're
getting game audio too you get all the
weird squeaks from the bunny doing
anything he has should be fine wheezy
I'm going on the door Oh yikes if he
splits it with Don Oh wants a split all
right I could also run over there and
turn off the ps3 sabotage vicodin isn't
this beer is for all of us show i'm
gonna use this internet countdown timer
to get 30 second you still own a few
times that says five our twitter back i
can subtract when it hits four minutes
and 30 seconds all right get in there
all right get it everything go
laughs laughs second oh my god beer for
everyone to do and he's only the frog oh
good work it smells dirty I know dump it
over i'm jumping over this is that gold
club my yeah there was also an order in
there haha that's for you you might work
I'm rich [ __ ] now buy us beer thank
you you know writer brown man of the
people Rob's gonna run run run in here
with like another stipulation is it's
okay this is the best possible outcome
for that bed hell I was at nine months
hey bigger banana sundae yes thank you
thank you my lady hater nicely done all
right got his head that's a show for
this week last things last we had this
TGS swag bag we showed a couple of weeks
ago and last week we didn't there that's
a winner I had one of those at home I'm
knocked are married man and the winner
is can I get a drumroll muddy logarithm
oh yeah you know that deep what no I
just know what the word logarithm means
Oh math jokes I thought you said math
jokes Oh congratulate dress fuel your
name is Magic let us know Oh jokes
always winning stuff I lucky lucky son
of a gun should we go get some beer yeah
all right thanks very much everyone fry
you have to bring the jar though yes you
have a good read I'll take 12 of your
finest and you got a first payment
Singapore euro and payday I'm sorry does
that not okay yeah sure I've got
something in here uh is this no okay I
mean let's go get drinks alright thanks
very much everyone for watching turn
lobby for this week we'll see you next
week tuesday to the M Pacific
you